and I just announced today this comes
out this into the spider-verse gets
stunning new trailer ahead of New York
Comic Con mmm I was talking to Chris
Pratt about Comic Con what do you say
you know because he's got to go there
for guardians of the galaxy he's really
what he's like he goes I'm in the middle
this place and I just said to myself I
don't belong here yeah yeah it's a
different he is the nicest guy he goes
to a bunch of UFC events yeah yeah he's
been to one there's only one is that
where you talk too much
yeah the [ __ ] he came hunting was in
Utah oh nice yeah [ __ ] nicest guy
like so normal we run everybody good
hunter yeah real good good Archer people
forget he started off as a comedian
actor like you guys yeah he was like the
the funny guy what was that show he was
on the office Clarkson parks are correct
right yeah like the fudgey yeah back
then and he's all jacked yeah it sounds
like dude you're gonna be the next
action here he's like what here's a
boatload of Stewart let's do that I
don't even think it was that I think he
just lost the weight and everybody went
oh you know he was a wrestler in high
school in college was he really in
college yeah Daniel yeah good wrestler
he took us off I saw him wrestling with
Nogueira yeah he actually looked pretty
good who's wrestling with Nogueira yeah
there's video of him wrestling the
Chimera brothers yeah and I was like
damn that dude knows what he's doing I
have no idea he was a you know wrestling
I thought a a farm in like outside of
Seattle and raises animals and actually
has like a farm like a a real
I think the way they caught just like
very humane Ethical Treatment of the
animals like the animals are all like
super adjusted to human beings and then
when they whack them they just take him
into a room and put one in their brain
and he does it or this is just as great
it's him and Nogueira yeah like this but
for you know I had no idea I still use a
normal actor like most time when you
watch actors like look at this [ __ ]
ya know set up everything ya know he
knows how to wrestle he wrestled in
college and in high school well you know
if he's feeling frisky the UFC's looking
fighters these days I don't know what
he's looking to do paying that guy that
guy's making twenty million dollars a
movie how the [ __ ] you gonna pay him for
that well just get out
that's star-lord bro
come up with your own whiskey bro who's
someone else besides star-lord - what
else what other movies did you do he's
gonna galaxy Jurassic Park dinosaurs
dinosaurs Rasik partystar laughter yeah
and here's the thing he came in like you
know there was already Jurassic Park
before and he came in with a new
Jurassic Park hotness with no hiccups
everyone was like [ __ ] with this new
Jurassic Park there was not a god better